effortlessly charming and a classic that
is how many was still described the
original you know who a perfect
collaboration between developers level
five and the legendary animation house
studio ghibli
[Music]
the fairytale that game was a
masterclass in storytelling and without
Studio Ghibli's involvement and simple
ninokuni two revenant Kingdom there is a
sense of casualness and lack of focus
against a backdrop of excellent combat
and amazingly addictive city building
sim
this pervasive indifference can be seen
throughout much of the games for the odd
our story for the first game weaved a
tale that captivates and pushes you
along ninokuni to becomes a tedious
cycle of fetch quests and recruiting
allies we're attempting to right the
wrongs of fractured land
[Music]
it would have been much more palatable
if it did not show a mishmash of teams
and ideas without a Korean focus that
ties everything together
with his kingdom gone motto ninokuni -
is spent trying to establish a better
sea state evans loss and his tireless
ambitions great and everlasting happily
ever after is infectious and players
will soon find themselves gleefully
awaiting the next finished facility or
in how great to be completed
it all ties into the general gameplay as
well providing players with improve and
new abilities gear quest and more
delightful banter to be had there
is plenty of combat in no Kuni - and it
is an excellent display of systems and
design that does not get old no matter
how far players are into the storage
assuring the first iterations balance of
movement in real-time and turn-based
planning combat here is our action and
chaotic in the best way
the triumvirate of weapons armor and
skills are right for experimentation
leading to devastating combinations that
can help players tackle harder enemies
aside from your party Ellen is also
joined by the magical higgledy-piggledy
adorable and mental beings who can lend
a hand in combat in the most charming of
ways the higgledy-piggledy are
unpredictable charming and powerful and
can often be the missing element that
can turn the time
[Music]
outside of small skill fights there are
also RTS like armies commish's on the
overall play from four different
varieties of Units range spears swords
or hammers or dents around Evon combat
is initiated when opposing forces come
into H and the rock paper scissors'
nature of and strength of the units will
require your temptation of your army
ninokuni Tzu revelon Kingdom is quite
unlike its predecessor but modern mixer
for it in complementary systems a
dangerously addictive city simulator and
wonderful combat it contains the usual
JRPG truck of innumerable things to do
and gather but for all the hours that
were spent who utterly enjoyable
well not as charming the second time
around
shrilling combat and engrossing city
builder makes ninokuni two revenant
Kingdom a wolf Wow epic
[Music]
you